well when Chris Paul was there it was
the Hornets yeah but I was defense too I
remember they changed to the Pelicans I
had I was like they should have left it
at the harness like the Hornets were
fire the harness was fired while we
changed that bro well y'all got Pelicans
out there though the Pelican flag we
don't got Pelicans bro I saw one Pelican
wait there's no Pelicans in [__] New
Orleans I saw one Pelican bro this is
this is in the truck and that was this
year Boo this is it was last year bro
what a terrible name for a franchise if
there's no [__] Pelicans they don't
even have hornets out there
I mean we knew that this should have
named the voodoo or something the voodoo
is the voodoo [__] real in New Orleans
yeah that's it definitely because you
can feel it in the air when you go out
there you could smell it like
it's just it's just a feeling out there
like do you know [__] out there
be putting Voodoo hexes on [__]
or I don't know I don't know I don't
think so not that I know of if there is
I would want to know yeah because I
won't I won't do Voodoo People
you would do some voodoo on somebody
yeah for sure you cast a spell yeah good
spell them like what kind of never see
the best would you ever make a like
maybe make a chick Fall in Love with You
cast that spell
nah not this Bell but just make
everything go how I want to go I think
it's it's safe to say it's going pretty
well for you if a girl fall in love with
you bro like if you maybe girlfriend bro
you asking you asking for something that
you really don't want bro girls crazy
bro but if you cast a spell it could be
any girl it could be Nicki
JLo you don't want Nikki and love what
you need they're like bro if a girl that
loves you bro she she brother she crazy
bro I don't want no girl that crazy with
me so you are trying to prevent women
from falling in love with you actively
nah nah just
not right now it's a cool in love okay
not knowing Voodoo in love Voodoo in
love is lame boy I'll do anything right
that's like Christian rock crazy yeah I
don't like that that's crazy to me yeah
you don't want a girl with your face
tatted on there
yeah that I wouldn't respect that she
tagged up my table right there Christian
rock with a [__] knife
that's her that's her [__] artwork
B plus J forever J is Jonathan blueface
she started a heart
bro it was a [__] I don't have a knife
don't do it with your nail bruh
I'll try it is this a this is a great
chain you have here uh how new is this
chain
um this was in like December that [__]
is serious do you feel like because I do
feel like when we see a lot of young
artists we always hear kind of
financially they make decisions when
they first get a lot of money that they
regret are you being pretty smart with
your money I'm being British what are
you doing with it you investing I did
not want to buy this thing okay first
thoughts like just because I know like
man this [__] cost a lot for nothing
like right bro tax write-off exactly a
prop prep right I remember like being in
a project like
200.
[Music]
wow I know
that's a lot so what are you doing with
the rest of your money
buying real estate real estate
Providence at home yeah
is it that I can imagine the is the
property value pretty pretty low you
could get in pretty low right now
um like they got fixer uppers they got a
lot of fixer upwards that's that's like
New Orleans get intensified quick like
well I know Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
had a house in the French Quarter right
I ain't gonna lie bro they got they got
Brad Pitt and Angela Jolie houses in New
Orleans like you drive past that but
you're gonna know like oh that's one of
the houses like they crazy like big
thought process on the on their cribs
crazy
they got [__] like you can rent out like
oh you could like right now like I'm
saying like Okay properties yeah they're
getting properties out there I think
they got divorced though for real so
somebody one of them two owns the house
now I don't think both of them to do
anymore
see that's what happens you fall in love
you get married and then you break up
and you have to give you have to split
everything in half that's one that's I'm
not getting married don't get married
because then you get divorced and the
girl gets half that chain you have to
cut that [__] thing in half I'm not
getting married yeah I'm not trying to
get married